اخبار العالم باجاز من غرفه اخبار الجزيره
اهلا بكم مقتل مستوطنه اسرائيليه واصابه
اخر في اطلاق نار قرب مستوطنه في الخليل
وقوه الاحتلال تعلن المدينه منطقه عسكريه
مغلقه
ومستوطنوني يهاجمون سيارات فلسطينيه على
حاجز بيت ايل بينما تصف حماس والجهاد
عمليه الخليل بانها رد طبيعي على
الاستيطان والتهويدات
بعد لقائه وفدا اكواس فينياميه المجلس
العسكري في النيجر يعلن فتره انتقاليه من
ثلاث سنوات واكواس تؤكد معارضتها للفتره
الانتقاليه مفوض المجموعه يقول للجزيره ان
خيار تدخل العسكري لا يزال قائما بينما
رصدت الجزيره دوريات اولى لمتطوعين موالين
للمجلس العسكري في العاصمه ومناطق حدوديه
السلطات الروسيه تعلن اعتراض طائرات مسيره
اوكرانيه هاجمت مناطق بضواحي موسكو وتعلق
العمل في اثنين من مطارات العاصمه بضع
ساعات كاف تقول انها استعاده السيطره على
ثلاثه كيلومترات مربعه قرب بخموت وتقر
بصعوبه الوضع في جبهه
[موسيقى]
يحيون الذكرى الرابعه والخمسين لحرق
المصلى القبلي في المسجد الاقصى المبارك
على يد المتطرف من اصل استرالي مايكل
دانيس روحانا حيث شب الحريق بالجناح
الشرقي للمصلى والتهم محتوياته كامله بما
فيها منبر صلاح الدين الايوبي التاريخي
معلقين بانه مازال مشتعلا بسبب سياسات
التهويد ضد الاقصى الى اللقاء